president met Pat the American public is
growing restless we need a plan to keep
everyone quarantined in the living rooms
hello Netflix the country needs you do
it now you're not serious right not
serious I am as serious as an anime fan
complaining about a new season of shows
now are you gonna do as I say or you
just gonna sit there and keep letting
innocent people die no sir I mean yes I
mean I'll do it right now they're
rushing to their homes you've saved us
all president mad mad what did you do
was that the final season of stranger
things a new season of nailed it no none
of that desperate times call for
desperate measures my friend so we had
to pull out the big guns we had to
release the king the king the tiger king
[Applause]
[Music]
hey y'all you cool cats and kittens
welcome to film theory the perfect show
for all your quarantined binging needs
of binging can we just all stop and talk
about Netflix's new seven part document
now if you haven't seen it yet you
should or at least the first few parts
of this thing add it to your to watch
lists after re-watching the office
seasons 1 through 5 for the umpteenth
time
let me explain Tiger King to you this
way imagine the craziest movie plot you
could possibly think of with like the
most over-the-top characters and then
throw what you just imagined away
because Tiger King is even more extreme
basically the show begins as a glimpse
into the quirky subculture of private
citizens who raised Tigers but then
quickly spirals out of control into a
world of polygamy holtz who wear animal
print drug smuggling attempted murders
actual murders presidential campaigns
meat trucks Tigers in suitcases and bad
country music lots and lots of bad
country music - in my first album I
thought I gonna [ __ ] my second album
starstruck there's 28 songs and 16
minute videos but it's not just the
twists and turns in the story Tiger king
is also just a non-stop parade of
impossible characters who somehow exist
in real life you would never assume
there was one person in the world like
this and yet Tiger King introduces us to
several dozen of them and they are like
the worst people ever don't get me wrong
there are some gems in there but most of
them are just awful awful human beings
when one of the most relatable of the
group is a former drug kingpin who
casually speaks about watching his
henchmen hack up an FBI informant with a
machete
you know that you're in that part of
YouTube again except this is a Netflix
territory what am I gonna tell the feds
or the judge your honor I did not shoot
him not use the circular saw his neck it
was somebody else still there there's
people like Doc antal a ponytailed
quote-unquote doctor Tiger breeder and
possible polygamist cult leader there's
Jeff Lowe the exotic cat owner / breeder
/ felon whose net worth is probably
anywhere between 10 million dollars and
negative ten million dollars oh and it's
just worth noting that he's an
all-around creepy dude who is definitely
not gonna hit on his family's new nanny
nanny I said you can get a nanny as long
as I get to pick her if you can bring
anyone why bring in one that's not
enjoyable to look at and the list goes
on the sheer volume of missing limbs and
missing teeth and this docu-series is
staggering a lot of people think Tigers
took my legs now it actually happened
from a zipline accident and yet even
when you surround yourselves on all
sides by the most insane characters you
can possibly imagine to outshine Amal
I'm talking of course about Joe exotic
he's a completely insane gay gun-toting
drug addict fanatic it was real he was
like a mythical character living out in
the middle of go homo and his bitter
rival to the death animal rights
activist Carol Baskin yo you cool cats
and kittens it's Carol it big cat
rescued one of the many many stories
that the doctor series covers is the
ongoing feud between these two where
Carol is trying to get Joe zoo shut down
for the mistreatment of Tigers Joe
exotic hates Carol and everything she
stands for so much that he hired a hit
man to killer failed and is now serving
a 22-year prison sentence as a result
meanwhile Carol is walking free which
should be a victory right I mean she's
the one fighting on behalf of the
animals
it's a bit more complicated than that
sure at a glance mild-mannered Karel
Baskin probably doesn't strike you as
being evil devious or even unpleasant
the woman's wardrobe is exclusively cat
prints she vlogs from her bicycle she's
dedicated her entire life to ending
animal cruelty but what infuriates
people like Joe exotic is her apparent
hypocrisy she fights against putting big
cats in cages and yet there are cat
filled cages all around big cat rescue
the organization that Carol essentially
inherited after her husband's mysterious
disappearance big cat rescue fights
against people like Joe breeding Tigers
and exploiting the animals for profit
and yet we see footage throughout the
doc you series of her allowing paying
customers to get up close and personal
with their cats guests tour the
sanctuary take tons of pictures and even
help feed the cats if you're taking
photos and stuff it'd be great if you
would use the hashtag Big Cat Rescue
it's so funny because the very people
that are against braiding used to do the
same thing so Carol is trying to put a
stop to the most lucrative aspects of
big cat ownership while also allegedly
doing similar things herself that's
gonna make a couple people mad oh yeah
and she also may have killed her husband
and fed his dead body to the Tigers to
the whole world wondering would you
actually grind your husband up feed him
to the tiger so there's no evidence you
see Carol inherited the big cat rescue
when her husband Dan Lewis just up and
disappeared one day never to be heard
from again
and Carol was the one to profit which
has caused her detractors people like
Joe exotic to concoct some absolutely
insane theories about her killing him
and then feeding the body to the hungry
Tigers leaving no scrap of evidence or
no scrap of dawn behind it seems crazy
right you want to feel bad for her
except the more she talks well let's
just say that she's not doing herself
any favors if I were gonna you know
somebody wanted to kill you then they
would put like sardine oil all over you
something that scat wants to eat not
something the cat wants to drool on wow
that was oddly specific there Carol
fitnah renas hands Carol you might want
to stop talking I think that these
people are smart enough to only
they're very closest circle of people
that they've got good dirt on to dispose
of a body unless you heart them out
right there I guess you know what I'm
just gonna stop you right there
suffice it to say to this day the case
of Dawn's disappearance remains open
Carroll has not done the best job of
clearing suspicion around her and
investigators are hopeful that the
success of Tiger king the docu-series
will bring about more information so I'm
here to do exactly that not solve the
case by any means definitely not but I'm
here to provide a little bit more
information scientific information is it
possible for Joe's theory Joe's Tiger
theory to be right could Don have
actually been fed to the figurative
wolves by being fed to the literal
Tigers if I were a tiger king looking to
dispose a body of my own would my Zoo
full of exotic creatures be a valid
option this is unquestionably one of the
most insane theories that we've ever
looked into it over 220 episodes of this
series I just think it goes to prove the
point the truth really is stranger than
fiction so here are the fact that we
have to work with on August 18th 1997
big cat breeder and multi-millionaire
Don Lewis was seen for the last time
near Tampa Florida
insert Florida joke here according to
the doc you serious he'd been having
arguments with his young wife Carol it
had even gone so far as to seek a
restraining order from her two months
before his disappearance daddy never
really involved the law in anything for
him to go down there and write that out
and present it before a judge was major
in the court filing Don claimed that
Carol had threatened to kill him on more
than one occasion and that she had two
guns available to her according to some
of his friends around this time Don was
also angling to divorce Carol if Don
Lewis had gotten the divorce with Carol
the way Don would have worked she would
have been left with really nothing many
who knew Don agree that he wasn't
exactly a one-woman kind of guy and the
fact that he was making frequent trips
to Costa Rica was apparently a huge
source of friction between him and Carol
who had good reason to believe that Don
had a girlfriend down there in fact Don
was planning to leave for Costa Rica
right around the time that he went
missing
Don started to tell me something he said
Kenny if I can pull this off it will be
the slickest thing I ever did in my life
August 19th the day after Dawn's
disappearance Carol reported him missing
shortly thereafter Dawn's van was found
abandoned at a tiny airport nearby do
you think it was planted I think someone
else drove the van there I don't know if
it was planted there does this mean that
Don Luis flew a plane down to Costa Rica
and intentionally disappeared himself
maybe but it doesn't seem likely at
least according to Don's lawyer Joe
Fritz it's impossible with the size and
types of planes at Don head that I know
that he could non-stop go from here to
Costa Rica
besides Don's longtime personal
assistant and McQueen claims that when
he was flying down to Costa Rica
he flew commercial out of Miami in the
wake of his disappearance detectives
looked around the forty acre big cat
sanctuary that Don and Carol lived on
they also did aerial passes over the
property and found nothing
shortly thereafter Carol allegedly broke
into an McQueen's office trailer when no
one else was around the will and the
power turning they were all taking on
the office that day Carol would later
produce that very will will that add
itself some very unusual language isn't
it suspicious that the power of attorney
says upon my disappearance is that
normal verbage I have in 37 years
never seen it say for disappearance
everybody anticipates our debt but who
in the world anticipates disappearance
it was a will that was also quite
favorable to Carol who retained the
property the cats and the lion's share
of Don's wealth pardon the pun you
inherited only 10% of his estate
Carol so it's not hard to imagine how
foul play might have been afoot but
again we're not interested in the what
or the why it's all about the how could
the Tigers they kept on their land have
had anything to do with Dawn's
disappearance let's start off by seeing
if that's even possible Don Luis weighed
about 170 pounds at the time of his
disappearance and a tiger in captivity
eats about 9 to 18 pounds of meat per
day when it's fed five times a week
given that Carol reported Don missing
after just one day it means there's
about a 24 hour window where the body
had to have been completely eaten in
other words it would take between 9 and
19 captive Tigers to consume that much
meat in such a short frame of time now
would Kerala have had access to that
many tigers in 1997 Don Luis claimed
that they had a hundred and thirty-two
exotic cats on the
look big cat rescue probably had nowhere
near enough adult tigers to actually do
the job you see in the 90s the vast
majority of cats that were kept at the
big cat rescue were much smaller cats
like Bobcats in Lynx we started in 1992
with the purchase of a bobcat who was
going to be killed by taxidermists at an
auction the following year we bought 56
Bobcats and links from a fur farm the
next year 28 Bobcats and lynx the
following year 22 more Bobcats and links
in the docu-series former exotic animal
owner dennis hill suggests that he sold
don and carol their very first tiger in
1995 just two years before Dawn's
disappearance I believe that I sold Don
and Carol loose our very first tiger in
1995 so even if Don and Carol bred their
new tiger immediately and big cat rescue
did breed its cats back in those days
prior to Carol taking over none of those
tiger cubs would have been full-sized by
the time that Don dissapeared
considering it takes Tigers about five
years to reach its full size it's also
highly unlikely that Carol and Don would
have gone out and bought a dozen more
full-sized Tigers during that two year
span as the docu-series suggests big
cats are typically purchased as cubs and
adolescence when audiences and families
can interact with them and thus the zoo
can make money off of them after that
the Tigers just becomes big and
expensive and not all that profitable
then when they get to be that age there
are enough ignorant people out there who
will then take in that tiger and a year
later that cats two or three hundred
pounds now at this point you're probably
saying to yourself so what if carol
didn't have enough tigers to do the job
she definitely had plenty of other
exotic cats around to devour a body and
that's very true Carol undoubtedly had
enough cats around to consume 170 pounds
of meat in a single day but the issue
here isn't the meat it's the bones
you got to keep the bones out of the
cave meat what we really need to know is
whether Carol had the right types of
animals available to her to get rid of
all the evidence because remember the
authorities looked around the sanctuary
and found nothing these Tigers have such
an acidic stomach that when you feed
them a whole turkey there's no bones
that come out okay it's gone so the
digestion of bone fragments might not be
a huge hurdle breaking the bones into
bite-sized pieces certainly is a
housecat for example doesn't have the
bite strength to break say a human femur
into manageable chunks and while we
don't know the species demographics of
the hundred and thirty-two exotic cats
that Don claimed owned back in 1997 we
do know that they had a lot of Bobcats
and a lot of links and probably just one
adult tiger it means that if Carroll fed
her husband to the cats which she
adamantly denies to this day she would
have had to have killed her husband and
then put her trust in a bunch of
medium-sized cats who are domesticated
from infancy by Donna no less to not
leave any bones behind even though
that's exactly what medium-sized cats do
when they consume large prey whose bones
are too big for their medium-sized jaws
to break Bobcats have a bite force of
approximately 110 pounds per square inch
Lynx have even less bite force than
Bobcats meanwhile a human femur takes
1700 psi to snap so clearly clearly it's
gonna take a cat much bigger to get rid
of every part of that human body and
there's no cat bigger than a tiger whose
bite force is a whopping 1050 psi weight
the Tigers bite force isn't enough to
snap a human femur I mean it's not like
I could do it or anything but guess I'm
just surprised that even a tire can't
manage to do it well it means that if
Carroll did feed her husband to the
Tigers and left no trace she may have
had to free break some of the bigger
bones herself and would you know it
there is a theory for that Herald's meat
grinder there is quite a bit of talk
about this in tiger king and people in
Dawn's circle our myth that carols meat
grinder was never tested for Dawn's DNA
so did Carol have a meat grinder
available to her in 1997 yes
was it the meat grinder shown in
operation in tiger King No one of
Carol's numerous issues with Tiger king
is that the producers showed a different
and far larger meat grinder on screen
than the one that she actually owned
back at the time
all claims that she had herself a small
butcher boy meat grinder quote one of
those little tabletop Hand Crank things
presumably similar to this we had a meat
grinder if you've ever seen a butcher
boy meat grinder it's about that big
around
well there are meat grinders out there
capable of grinding down large bones
from large mammals Carol says she didn't
own one of them and nobody seems to be
refuting that claim with any sort of
evidence so it looks like we'll have to
assume the only things on the premises
capable of grinding bones we're the
exotic cats themselves and as we've
established animals known to be on the
property in 1997 aren't up to the task
of making a 170-pound human body
disappear but what about all the animals
that aren't known to us after all we are
talking about a man Don Luis who
allegedly did a lot of things
off-the-grid like burying gold bars
keeping secret girlfriends on the side
buying planes in cash and then flying
them around without recording those
flights in any log because they didn't
have a valid pilot's license so it's not
surprising that there's no record of the
exact animals that Don Luis had on his
property all were able to piece together
is that a lot of them were bobcats and
Lynx and at least one of them was a
tiger but there were 132 exotic cats and
all what if there were other exotic cat
breeds on the property would any of
those breeds possibly have been better
suited for disposing human bone are
there any big cats out there with a bite
force of over 1700 psi well let's take a
look and see and a quick shout out to
the FBI agent who's now been assigned to
monitor my activity after all these
super creepy Google searches that I've
been doing first up let's look at lions
seems like it should be the obvious
first choice the lion is the king of the
jungle rights well it turns out that the
king of the jungle is generally smaller
than a tiger and also has itself a
smaller jaw a lion's bite force is only
about 650 psi so while it can take care
of some bones in the human body it's not
the one-stop human body disposal shop
that we're after same thing goes with
leopards whose bite force is only 305
psi and with those out of the way we're
actually running out of apex predators
pretty quickly here folks
I guess 1700 psi is too much to ask
unless of course a Jaguar can deliver
more bite force than a tiger and why
would they Jaguars are smaller than
Tigers they
less than Tigers and their bite forces
over 9,000 well no it's not over 9,000 I
just wanted to say that but the Jaguars
bite force is the biggest of the bunch
it's actually at 2,000 psi it turns out
that they have remarkably strong bites
and guess what they bite with enough
force to break through the human field
so there you have it folks the
Hillsborough County Sheriff recently
announced that he's seeking leads on the
case again anybody got any details of
whether there were Jaguars on the
property at the time because if there
was a Jaguar cage on Carroll's property
back in 1997
it seems like the place to investigate
Joe exotic maybe the tiger king but
Carroll Baskin may have been the
undercover Jaguar Queen the entire time
or you know what she might have just
killed her husband and hid his body
somewhere in the forty acres of land
that they have something tells me the
cops didn't do that thorough of a job
covering that huge amount of territory
but hey that's just a theory Oh film
theory and cuts but don't cut up a human
body and feed it to wild animals that
would be a big no-no
[Music]
you